hello everyone and welcome to another
really really wild game from round seven
of this year's saint louis rapid
tournament it's uh resafiroja versus
yanni ponmashi alireza has been leading
the tournament so far after day one and
day two even after that loss to fabiano
caruana that we've shown
other than that he's been having a
spectacular event but jan is doing uh
fairly well himself uh and this game is
just uh like i said really wild already
manages to surprise jan very early on uh
with a nice uh semitarash uh and uh jan
just all of a sudden uh is down the
exchange already on move eight so let's
see how this happened and how the game
continued so alireza opens with d4 we
have knight to f6 c for e6 knight to f3
and d5 so a standard queen's gambit
declined knight to c3 and c5 young goes
for the
uh semitarash uh and now we have e3c
characters on d5 um still the more
popular but alireza goes for e3 knight
to c6 and now pawn to a3 we have d cap
presidency for bishop captures and pawn
to e6 now preparing b5 and there are
some games that reach this position
quite a lot of them actually where
castles was played also bishop uh just
back to d3s and on with the captures and
c5 offering a queen trade is a known
move but here alireza plays bishop back
to 82 and it is now as of move eight
that we have a completely new game so uh
how uh uh how can a young react to this
well of course uh his plan was b5 and as
alireza did not stop it he will uh
execute b5 uh we have queen to c2
alireza offers a pawn here and jan says
all right let's see let's see what you
got and he accepts the challenge he
plays c characters on d4 he captures
knight characters knight characters and
queen captures on d4 and now what was
alireza's plan here uh well his plan was
knight the d5 and already we have some
fireworks uh on the board
uh the
uh queen of course cannot capture the
knight as the bishop covers that but you
could capture with the pawn however then
queen to c6 check and you might lose a
rook so how do you how do you play this
it's actually incredibly um
incredibly sophisticated and in order to
survive this you have to play queen to
e5 with czech yan didn't play this yeah
ayan played knight captures on d5 but i
will show you because it's uh really
really an incredible line queen to e5
check is what you have to play and now
after bishop e3 knight captures on d5
and now queen to c6 with check and now
uh
check this out uh you cannot play kinked
aking to d8 even though it seems like uh
like a reasonable move if you play king
to d8 uh you just get obliterated bishop
captures on d5
rook to a7 so black kind of keeps the
rook into the game but now queen to b6
would check now attacking the rook and
after rook to c7 now bishop to c6
preparing rook to d1 check so here
bishop to d6 and now you're gonna castle
queenside bring a rook into the attack
and after bishop to d7 you're just gonna
play f4 and here black would resign
there is no move for the black queen
once the black queen moves of course
you're just gonna capture on d6 and
that's it there's no
move the black queen can make here
that'll be in any way useful so what you
would have to do after this queen to c6
check is actually play king to e7 and
now after queen captures an a8 you're
gonna play ninth characters on e3 of
course if captures then capture so first
one check queen to e7 with check and
only after king to f6 you're gonna play
f captures on e3 now your queen is
defending the e3 pawn but now bishop c5
attacks the queen and the three pawn
still hangs and now castles with check
this is a
really wild stuff uh king g5 and now
queen to a8 um
the queen can now get back into the
defense and even though you could
capture an e3 you're just going to allow
this rook to come into the game with
tempo so best is just sorry now that
best is just f5 the black king will have
some uh safety there and this should be
good for black
and white also so that's the idea behind
the position and what already prepared
for nipple but nepo just plays knight
captures on d5 he says you can have your
rook let's let's uh see what you got so
queen to c6 check king to e7 and queen
captures on a8 we have queen to e5 with
check kink to f1 and now nip would just
place a queen to d4 the thread being
queen to d1 checkmate so how can all it
is stop this well uh bishop the g5 check
now the rook covers the d1 square so
he's not going to get checkmated king to
d7 only move uh otherwise your bishop
can see it just hangs uh with queen
captures on c8 so here bishop characters
on d5 the only way to fight for
advantage queen characters and now you
trade queens captures captures and rook
to d1 and here
alireza says uh
all right i'm of the exchange you're up
upon and you don't you do have the
bishop's pair but at some point i'm
gonna play h4 bring the rook to h3 bring
the rook into the game and it should be
a fairly fairly easy win so bishop to b7
we have bishop back to e3 and now ian
executes pawn to b4 stopping all it is a
spawn to b4 and also activating his dark
square bishop so a captures bishop
captures and now bishop to d4
alireza gets his bishop to this long
diagonal even though
h4 also could be considered as you want
to get this rook into the game as soon
as possible uh and now we have rook to
c8 yan not interested in wasting time
defending the g7 pawn he just brings the
rook into the game he has the bishop
pair he wants to play bishop c6 bishop
b5 put this bishop on this diagonal this
bishop will control this diagonal maybe
even this diagonally in the future and
if the rook comes to c2 it should be
very unpleasant for alireza and alireza
says all right i agree i'm not going to
go after the after the pawn and he plays
h4 now rook to h3 is coming
and now rook to c to jan again does not
defend the pawn and here
you could go after the pawn but if
bishop captures on g7 now then you
no longer control this diagonal and now
how do you defend rook captures on c2 uh
there is uh one good way but it's not
bishop to d4 if you play bishop to d4
then just bishop captures rook captures
rook c1 check and you lose the rook on
h1 so instead of this uh bishop retreat
you would have to play king to g1
actually allow the character on f2 and
after rook captures an f2 now
threatening all sorts of nasty
discoveries uh now bishop to d4 now the
threat is king captures on f2 so now
bishop captures on d4 rook characters
and not rook captures on v2 and you
would get at this end game
two rooks against the bishop and rook
but uh jan would be up to pawn so white
should be better but not enough to
actually win uh so instead we have rook
to h3
and now finally g6 now jan says all
right you've
spent all your moves developing i now
have to defend my pawn and then f5 is
coming as well so rook f3 attacks f7 eon
plays pawn to f5 and now pawn to h5 uh
trying to
trade off uh a pair of pawns here and
then maybe even open up the the h file
for the rook maybe put the rook on the g
file to attack the pawn so here we have
a5 and now h captures on g6 h captures
on g6 and now rook the g3 just going
after the g6 pawn
and here uh jan defends it with a very
very neat trick
bishop to a6 check king to g1 and now
bishop to e2 with tempo attacking the
rook on d1 and now preparing to shift
the bishop over to h5 to defend the g6
pawn so rook to a1 and now bishop to h5
and now how can alireza make progress
here the b4 bishop defends the a5 pawn
the h5 bishop defends the g6 spawn
and the king will very likely defend the
d5 pawn so here already goes rook to d3
he might have some ideas of moving the
bishop uh and going after the d51 and at
some point even bishop to c3 might be an
option so here bishop e2
attacks the rook rook to e3 and nipple
repeats bishop to h5 but now we have
rook to e5 this is a very nice rook lift
for alireza king the d6 defending the d5
pawn and now rook to e8 at least this
way alireza gets his rook activated king
d7 kicking away the rook rook to b8 now
we have bishop to e2 uh waiting to see
what alireza will do and now rook to b6
also uh you could go after the pawn via
the g6 uh the g8 square but alareza
decides to go for rook to b6 and now
just pawn to g5 nipple advances and
maybe rook to g8 was better as this also
would prevent pawn to g5
so here rook to g6 going after the g5
point now just pawn to g4 and here
finally we have bishop the c3 offering a
trade of bishops which will also remove
the defender of the a5 pawn and here
what do you play a very interesting idea
and this uh you would have to be very
very ambitious to go for this and you
know i really want to fight that until
the uh
every last pawn is to play rook captures
on c3 be captures bishop captures and
now you would have a bishop pair against
the rook pair you would be up two pawns
uh that including the past d-pawn and
the past a pawn and it could be could
could get ugly uh for example you put
your bishops on b2 and b3 and you are
controlling all of these squares uh it's
very easy to uh
to start promoting this spawn uh white
would have to give back at least one
rook so here instead of this nipple goes
for bishop to c5 now he wants to put
pressure on f2 and now we have bishop
captures on a5 rook captures on b2 and
now bishop back to c3 attacking the rook
rook to b3 attacks the bishop on c3 and
now bishop back to e5 and here
uh the position is fairly equal and if
uh
you play something like bishop to d3 or
bishop to b5 then uh chances are this
would just end up in a very quick draw
however nipple played bishop to c4
and here alireza actually has a winning
position but it's uh very very difficult
to win it because uh you you have to
really see it and also alireza was
incredibly low on time he only had
seconds on the clock whereas nipple had
i believe uh maybe even uh you know
close to 10 minutes as nepal usually
plays plays fairly quickly but feel free
to pause the video and try to find this
spectacular position that
all there is i missed while i give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on uh
finding this brilliancy and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is a rook to a8 we can even do a slow
rook lift as it goes all the way up to
the board and now
that you see it of course you again
believe it uh now there is no defense
for black whatever you play uh just uh
rook to g7 check and that's it this row
controls the entire eighth rank rook and
g7 will control the entire seventh rank
and the king will be forced to one of
these two squares of course you can't go
here the bishop covers that and that's
going to be it to give you an example
let's say rook b1 checking h2 and rook
captures on f2 seems like white is
getting destroyed here
but just rogue g7 check and that's it if
you go to e6 rook to e8 is checkmate
very unfortunate the bishop is defended
by the rook now and of course both of
these squares are covered by the bishop
so that's it and if you go to c6 it's
not much better
just rook to c8 with check and now how
do you play this you have to play
something you can either go to b6 or to
b5 uh but uh uh whatever you play the
rook on b1 with hey it will hang so for
example king to b5 just rook to b7 with
check and now even if the bishop goes
back to help out with the defense just
rook captures on b6 and after king
captures uh just rook to b8 with check
now the king has to move and now of
course the rook hangs rook captures on
b1 and that's it so that's why rook to
a8 in this position uh absolutely uh
spectacular but alireza misses it he uh
was convinced that he was a draw he
played rook to d1 and now indeed it is a
draw and here uh bishop to d3 stopping
the attack on the d5 pawn wrote the c1
attacking the bishop bishop to c4 bayern
rogue d1 bishop to d3 rook to c1 bishop
to c4 and rook to d1 and he was in this
position on mu 46 that alireza and jan
agreed to a draw as there is now nothing
more to be done here uh so really wild
game uh i i'm pretty sure already
surprised him with this bishop to a to
move and um then justian uh went into
this pawn grab and allowed the queen
queen to c6 check followed by this rook
capture uh even though you've seen the
line that uh instead of capturing queen
to e5 check and then that complicated
complicated line where your king ends up
for who knows where on h6 on h5 uh
you're going to play f5 uh i mean
absolutely crazy position uh but yeah
alireza did outplay him uh but uh uh
that's that's the easier part because
usually i mean everyone uh outplays jan
but then just yan just outplays them
back and then inside roy draw orijan
wins this or very very uh rarely he he
actually loses but yeah again uh he he
has shown the power of the bishop pair
the power of activity the power of
well-placed pieces and
it was just uh
also this was a really really beautiful
move here where all it is i just played
bishop to d4 attacked the g7 pawn and he
just played rook to c8 showing the power
of the bishop pair like i said going
here here and just rook to c2 uh this is
uh definitely worth a pawn and uh well
in the end the result is fair even
though alireza had a win and a beautiful
win in this position so i thought yeah
you might
i find it useful for your own games you
might have a similar position where you
might be able to take away the uh the
eighth and seventh rank from your
opponent's king and okay maybe it's not
going to be exactly the same but you
know
patterns patterns and patterns and you
know in the end you will win some game
using those patterns
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it i would like to wish a very
happy birthday to lenny and i would like
to thank uh conor kelly john merlino
damon targaryen and girish sharma for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
uh st louis rapid event until it
finishes uh so thank you all i will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day and if you have any of your own
favorite games do share it using hashtag
suggestion in the comments see you soon